If you've been watching these modules in the suggested order,
uh,
we have now finished the introductory part of the course.
We've covered cases on how to form an enforceable promise.
We have,
uh,
been introduced to a few cases on a defenses to enforcement and a couple of
cases,
uh,
having to do with remedies.
Now we're going to go back and take up in more depth,
uh,
how to create enforceable contracts and starting again with the concept of
consideration.
In an earlier lecture,
we talked about consideration as a traditional prerequisite for forming a
contract by introducing that concept with the classic Cesnet of a case,
a Hamer versus Sidway.
You remember that was the one where an uncle bribed his nephew to refrain from
drinking and using tobacco until he was 21 in Hammer.
The court found that there was consideration.
Today we consider a case called Kirksey versus Kirksey where the court
considered a promise that lacked consideration.
In other words,
a gratuitous promise.
The defendant in Kirksey wrote a letter to the plaintiff.
Uh,
angelical Kirksey is widowed sister in law.
After you learned of his brother's death,
he wrote,
if you come down and see me,
I will let you have a place to raise your family.
A,
the plaintiff had been squatting on public land,
which she could have secured,
but after receiving the letter,
she abandoned the land and moved her children about 65 miles to live with the
defendant,
the defendant,
how's the plaintiff for over two years.
But then forester to leave.
And the Cra Trial Court,
uh,
awarded the plaintiff $200.
Uh,
but the instant court that we're going to be,
uh,
focusing on reversed.
And so the central issue was simple.
Was the defendant's promise supported by consideration?
The court's opinion in this case is short and sweet.
The opinion begins with what is in effect a one sentence dissent by the
authoring judge who is inclined to hold that quote,
the loss and convenience which the plaintiff sustained and breaking up and
moving to the defendants.
A distance of 60 miles is sufficient consideration to support the promise
unquote the author and judge whoever is out voted.
He's outnumbered by the other judges on the court who quote think that the
promise on the part of the defendant was a mere gratuity and that inaction will
not lie for it's breach unquote.
With that,
the court reverses the lower court's opinion in,
uh,
just three sentences and rules for the defendant.
When we discussed Hamer versus Sidway,
we concluded that the nephews agreement to give up his legal right to engage in
certain vices counted as illegal detriment as consideration because it was
illegal detriment and a detriment to the promise or accounts this consideration.
How about in this case,
was there a detriment to the primacy and Kirksey?
Well,
yes,
she could have continued to squad on the public land and eventually secure it,
but instead she abandoned the property and traveled 60 miles and reliance on her
brother in law,
his promise.
So if consideration is either a detriment to the promise,
see,
or a benefit to the promise or the plaintiffs seems like she should win,
right?
Well,
wrong.
Reliance alone is not enough.
There must be a bargain,
a quid pro quo.
You remember that section 71 of the restatement.
Second of contracts,
states that to constitute consideration or performance or return promise must be
bargained for a promise for a return promise is bargained for if it's sought by
the promise or in exchange for the promise and is given probably the primacy in
exchange for that promise.
So was there a bargain for exchange and Kirksey versus Kirksey?
No,
at least the court which called the promise,
a mere gratuity,
not just a gratuity,
but a mere gratuity.
He didn't seem to think so.
Then again,
it can be difficult to distinguish a conditional promise from a bargain for
promise.
For another example,
imagine this offers made.
If you come to my house,
you can play with my dog is the promised their bargaining with you to persuade
you to visit or as the promise promise her.
Simply saying,
my dog is here.
So if you happen to stop by,
you can play with it.
The ladder is a gratuitous but conditional gratuitous promise.
Often we need extra facts to figure out whether a particular promise is offering
a quid pro quo,
uh,
or offering a conditional gratuity was the sister's conduct in the Kirksey's
case.
Bargain for?
Well,
not if it was not sought by the promise or an exchange for the promise.
When are we sure that it was not right?
What if the promissor is Jewish and his,
it's a Mitzvah for him to marry the widow of his brother,
mighty,
be willing to pay for her to come.
Generations of law students have wondered about the story of sister until Echo.
Why did her brother in law invite her to come stay with him?
Was the promise purely gratuitous or did he expect to get something out,
uh,
from her,
out of her moving,
uh,
closer to him.
And why did he later changed his mind and eject her from,
uh,
his property?
A 2006 article by William Casto and Val Rick's cast some light,
uh,
some new light on this question.
They found that under a federal law at the time,
squatters on federal lands and Alabama and elsewhere,
we're often able to obtain a preference on those lands that allowed them to
purchase the lands at below market price.
But the law only permitted one preference per person.
So if the brother in law had already exercised at PR preference on other land,
he may have sought to persuade Angelica to occupy the land and exercise a
preference,
buy it at a below market price,
and then transfer it back to him.
But if this is the story,
why was that Angelica evicted?
After two years?
Casto and Rick's find records indicating that the brother in law,
in fact,
gave joint possession of the property to his son who turned 21 around the time
Angelica was ejected once he turned 21.
The son was now of age enabled to exercise the preference himself.
Making Angelica is continued occupancy unnecessary.
These added details suggest that maybe a JELLCO's brother in law was in fact
seeking a quid pro quo in the lecture following Hamer versus Sidway.
I talked about the case of rickets versus Scott Thorn and introduce the doctrine
of promissory Estoppel.
Promissory Estoppel you'll remember,
allows courts to enforce promises even if there are not contracts because of
lack of consideration in rickets.
Remember a grandfather promised his granddaughter that he would pay her $2,000
plus interest so that she would,
uh,
not have to go to work anymore.
The grandfather,
the grand daughter,
quit her job,
but after the ground father died,
the executor of the grandfather's estate refused to pay the promise $2,000.
The court held that the promise was binding because the granddaughter relied on
the promise to her detriment and it'd be an equitable not to enforce it.
Remember that section 90 of the restatement second outlines the conditions for
promissory Estoppel,
a promise which the promise or should reasonably expect induce action or
forbearance on the part of the promise,
he or a third person and which does induce such action or forbearance is binding
if injustice can be avoided only by enforcement of the promise.
So did the brother-in-law's promise in Kirksey meet the requirements of
promissory Estoppel?
Yes.
A promise or who promises to give you a place to raise your family should
reasonably expect that the promise we'll induce you to abandon the land you are
squatting on and move a 65 miles and encourage either promises.
Did in fact induce the plaintiff to move.
So why didn't the court enforce the promise?
Well,
the easy answer is that when Kirksey was decided in 1845 promissory Estoppel was
not yet a thing in contract law.
Remember,
rickets is recognized as one of the genesis cases,
uh,
with regard to promissory Estoppel and it was not decided until 1898 further
Kirksey was decided in Alabama and Ricketts was decided in Nebraska.
Since law changes over time and can differ from place to place,
these factors might simply explain the outcome,
but I'm not going to let you off with just the easy answer nor food.
Most law professors,
you should also think of a if there are other ways that we can distinguish these
cases factually to explain the outcome.
One possible key differences that the promise or in Ricketts had passed away and
the available facts suggest that he's still intended for the granddaughter to
receive the gift.
It was the executor of the estate who refuse to pay.
While this is with this in mind,
the question in Ricketts was arguably less about whether the grandfather's
promise should have inner irrevocably bound him and more about how the
grandfather's estate should be divided among the descendants since the
grandfather apparently wanted his granddaughter wished for a while,
wanted his granddaughters,
what his granddaughters,
his wish for his granddaughter to receive this money until it's in the outcome
seems justified.
But in Kirksey it was the promise or who decided himself to take back is
gratuitous promise.
So with the doctrine of Estoppel aside,
the cases might also be reconciled by a rule that says an individual who makes
it gratuitous promise may later or may later revoke or more easily revoke that
promise,
but he must do it himself or make his intention to revoke posthumously clear to
the court.
Uh,
even if both of these cases may come out the same today under section 90 under
this theory of promissory Estoppel.
And I tend to think they would,
thinking through the factual differences in the cases is a useful exercise.
This is what common law is frequently about finding a potentially relevant
factual distinctions in order to reconcile seemingly,
uh,
unreconcilable,
and different outcomes.
A clever lawyer will often find factual distinctions that allow her to argue
that our client's situation is more similar to cases without comes more
favorable and more distinguishable from outcomes that she doesn't like.
So what have we learned?
A conditional gratuitous promise does not create a contract.
A contract requires bargain for exchange.
So even if a promise induces the primacy to take or for bear from taking a
certain action,
the promise will not be an enforceable contract if that action was not sought by
the promised or in exchange for his promise.